the starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks tonight taylor widener the
right-hander scratch from a scheduled
start last thursday against the padres
just a precaution he was feeling under
the weather no covet the quicker the
innings the better off he's going to be
there's a good start 94 right by segura
good start for taylor widener powers up
strikes out segura and then real muto
and ball four so harper walks 65th walk
of the season
gregorius hits a fly ball deep to right
center pavement smith is there
kyle gibson's going to get ground balls
and you got to play good defense behind
him which we found out he did the
phillies did not do
in his last outing against the dodgers
rojas is at it again boy is he hot
went 10 for 15 in four games against san
diego
and a strike three call to sinker
three-two pitch coming to mccutcheon
it's high ball four
and sure enough he hits it over there
deep to left peralta backing up
and david's got it
mccutcheon on a deep fly to left goes
first to second
yes he went corey blazer says yes three
strikeouts for widening
on the back foot that one is off gibson
by gregorius and into right center van
meter hustling for a second he's going
to make it standing up
bouncer back to the mounds and paid off
1-3 on the put out
here's bryce harper
3-1 pitch coming to harper
and a high fly ball out to right field
smith is going back toward the pole it's
gone
a towering home run for bryce harper and
the phillies jump out to a one-nothing
lead
and i'm not even sure how competitive
that pitch was i just think harper's
hands
were explosive to that pitch yeah up and
in
rbi number 50 home run number 22.
unbelievable rojas
into left center he's two for two
and a strike three called on the outside
quarter according to phil cousy as druva
cabrera didn't think so but he is down
looking for the second time tonight
fast ball up miller strikes out
2-1 pitch to jankowski and he skies it
to center
that's going to be easy for marta makes
the catch
side retired in order first time tonight
for widener
it's that one down the right field line
harper's on the run he's toward the well
makes the catch
swinging a miss
and the side is retired three strikeouts
here's a high fly ball
left center marte over
peralta over and david callsport makes
the
[Applause]
there's a catch of the missed by real
muto down on strikes flicks his bad away
as
he has to be thrown out by marshall
marshall rips one down the line his hot
streak continues it's in the corner and
varshall's on the move
he pulls into second it's a lead-off
double
[Applause]
and a strike three called
outside corner four strikeouts for
gibson it's beautiful pitch
so here comes josh rojos pressure josh
rojas
laughs in the face of pressure
3-1 is sent out to left-center and this
will tie the ball game
it's an rbi double for josh rojas and
we're tied at one stay hotties three for
three
squid shot stays fair
miller can't connect
bouncing ball miller's got it goes to
second for one back to first
and in time gibson hangs out of the bag
wow his long lean body was able to stay
on the bag as he fell to the ground and
the side is retired
left handed miguel aguilar comes on the
alaska usa federal credit union called
the bullpen he gets to face bryce harper
who has walked in homer
[Applause]
miguel aguilar got him with a curveball
brad miller on deck the first baseman
mccutcheon hits a fly ball to center
room for cattell
miguel aguilar one two three sixth
inning
three
drives it deep to right field harper at
the wall and it's gone
josh van meter
diamondbacks grab the lead
he has been since the all-star break the
extra base hit machine so far tonight a
double in a home run 12 extra base hits
since the all-star break
balls two strikes
and ball four jankowski walks jankowski
will be off and running on this pitch
and it's low ball four o'double draws a
walk so back-to-back walks
the pitch to the plate and a fly ball
behind short banking now rojas he's
under it and he's got it a big four
advance tonight for gene segura in an
overform
hammer v hager here jd hammer against
jake hager
and a breaking ball called strike three
that is a beautiful pitch from jd hammer
sure was
swinging to miss 96 from hammer
pitching change right-hander taylor
clark will get the eighth
yamuto reaches out and pokes it to
center for cattell martinez
he's over four
[Applause]
harper slugs it out to left here comes
peralta
two outs for taylor clark
here's the next one and that ball's hit
a mile in the air to right but it's
playable for pavon smith
in front of the fence out there he's got
it to retire the side david peralta for
three
mccutcheon running toward the line look
out hot plate
didn't get it
i think the fan caught the ball the fan
caught the ball
look he reached over though
we love when you bring your glove to the
game but you got to stay within the
boundaries major league baseball decided
that he did not interfere is being
allowed back into the seating area
either clipper the right hand they're a
win a pair of saves and nine appearances
this year
fly ball center field it's well struck
marte going back it's off the wall it's
still in play it's going to be a double
for miller
which means the tying run is coming to
the plate
ball four
and the o2 pitch
gets away from dalton varshall miller's
coming home nobody's covering home
it's a 3-2 game
jammed him popped it up can we get
somebody there david peralta has got it
it got a little too entertaining there
at the end but the diamondbacks hang on